Oh, morning, Angel. How'd you sleep last night? Good morning, yeah. I saw it really great. Moving around, moving around. Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry. Wait, a lot of kicking last night. Did you have any dreams? I know, I had dreams. I had this recurring thing that I just, I kept thinking like,
哦，早上好，安吉尔。昨晚睡得怎么样？早安，是的。我感觉非常好。到处走动，到处走动。好的，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。等等，昨晚踢得好厉害。你做梦了吗？我知道，我做梦了。我一直在想一件事，就是，
it was, you were running away from me. Oh, you're kind of breathy this morning. You just back up just a little bit. It was that, that's what you said in the dream. Dreams reality. No, see, right there, those exhales of depression is what really sparks. Okay, well bring your nose up close and smell it. You ready for this?
那是，你当时在躲我。噢，你今天早上呼吸声有点重。你稍微往后退一点点。就是那个，你在梦里就是这么说的。梦想照进现实。不，你看，就在那儿，那些充满压抑的叹气声才是真正的火花。好吧，把你的鼻子凑近点闻闻。准备好了吗？
Yeah. It's an all-new smart list. Smart, less. Smart, less. Smart, less. What do you got, a coffee milkshake? No, we've got a, like a smoothie milkshake. It's a milkshake.
好。这是一个全新智能列表。智能，更少。SmartLess。SmartLess。你这是什么，咖啡奶昔？不，我们有，有点像冰沙奶昔。这就是奶昔。
Almond butter and, you know, just a bunch of like healthy stuff. Have you guys seen, I know Jason, you haven't. The original Danish version of the killing. No, man. First of all, I know, I know I had you at Danish because you're like, what kind? Jesus. I'm so international.
杏仁黄油，你知道的，就是一堆健康的东西。你们看过吗，我知道杰森你没有。原版丹麦剧《谋杀》？没有，伙计。首先，我知道，我知道我用“丹麦”吸引了你，因为你会想：哪种的？天哪。我太国际化了。
That's for sure. Tell us about it. God, it's good. So we can get in here with the scissors and cut this out. Go ahead, Will. God, it's so, it's so, so good. Okay, wait, I started watching Boba Fett. That you have to check out.
那是肯定的。跟我们讲讲吧。天哪，太棒了。所以我们可以拿着剪刀进去把这个剪掉。说吧，威尔。天哪，太，太，太棒了。好吧，等等，我开始看《波巴·费特》了。那个你们必须看看。
Oh, that's the new Star Wars one. Yeah, sure. Did you and Scotty put on your comfy couch socks and taking a couple of episodes? Yeah, we put on our Star Wars onesies. Is it better than, what's the other one that's on, the Mandalorian? Is it better than that?
哦，那是新的《星球大战》系列。对，没错。你和斯科蒂穿上舒适的沙发袜看了几集吗？对，我们穿上了《星球大战》连体衣。它比——另一部正在热播的《曼达洛人》要好吗？比那个好吗？
It's just as good, yeah. That's a politic of you. Yeah, no, that's really good. Guys, we got serious people waiting to come on. People. Yeah, actually, I did a double book here. And you're welcome. Okay, well, I haven't said a thing.
一样好，对。你还挺会说话的。对，不，真的很棒。伙计们，有重要人物在等着上节目呢。人们。对，其实，我这里重复预约了。不用谢。好吧，我什么都没说。
Hush. Okay. Yeah, you will. The killing is Danish. It's a Danish show. I got it. Fellas, today's a tough one for me. Today's guests are from my dream list.
嘘。好吧。对，你会的。《谋杀》是丹麦的。这是一部丹麦剧。我懂了。伙计们，对我和说今天是个艰难的日子。今天的嘉宾来自我的梦想名单。
That is a list that I gave our producer Michael before we even began. These are people that we'll never get. They're just examples of the kinds of folks that I would die to be trapped in an elevator with. I never asked him for an update on pursuing these folks. All the notes. I never asked him for an update on pursuing these folks
那是我们在开始之前给制作人迈克尔的一份名单。这些人是我们永远请不到的。他们只是我渴望被困在电梯里的那种人的例子。我从没问过他追这些人进展如何。所有的笔记。我从没问过他追这些人进展如何。
because that would be a waste of my time. But a month ago, he surprised me with a text out of nowhere that said these guys were coming on. So, a tough day for me. These fellas are in a band. It is, in my opinion, the best band and has been since they started. They have a new band that we're going to talk about,
因为那会浪费我的时间。但一个月前，他突然发了一条短信给我一个惊喜，说这些人要来。所以，对我和说这是艰难的一天。这些伙计是一个乐队的。在我看来，这是最棒的乐队，而且自他们出道以来一直如此。他们有一个新乐队，我们要聊聊这个，
but the one you're going to know them from has consistently given us music that is never routine. It's always challenging in the best way and never two songs the same. They met in school along with their other bandmates and they've been playing together ever since. That's admirable. The smile.
但你们认识他们时的那个乐队一直给我们带来从不千篇一律的音乐。它总是以最好的方式充满挑战，绝没有两首歌是相同的。他们在学校里相识，还有他们的其他乐队成员，从那以后他们就一直在一起演奏。这令人钦佩。微笑。
Because they're as old as we are. They've released nine plus albums, sold over 30 million copies, won six Grammys, and were inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in 2019. Fellas, if this is a dream, I'm good to stay down. Smother me with a pillow and say night night. Please welcome from my favorite band in the world,
因为他们和我们一样老。他们发行了九张以上的专辑，售出超过3000万张，赢得六座格莱美奖，并在2019年入选摇滚名人堂。伙计们，如果这是一场梦，我愿意一直做下去。用枕头闷死我，然后说晚安吧。请欢迎来自我世界上最喜欢的乐队的，
Yes Will Radiohead, Tom York and Johnny Greenwood. No way. How the fucking way? I knew it. I knew it. When you said they had a new band, I was like, I know it because I've heard the new single. These guys are incredible.
等等，是电台司令乐队的汤姆·约克和强尼·格林伍德。不会吧。怎么可能？我早就知道。我早就知道。当你说他们有个新乐队时，我就想，我猜到了，因为我听过新单曲。这些人太不可思议了。
Are you kidding? Tom and Johnny, my God, what an honor and pleasure to have you guys here. Jason, we saw these guys together. Didn't we not like 2003? I don't remember if I was with you because I was probably in a blackout of pleasure. But sure, if you were there, great.
你在开玩笑吗？汤姆和强尼，天哪，能请到你们二位真是莫大的荣幸和喜悦。杰森，我们一起看过这几位。我们是不是大概在2003年看过？我不记得我当时是不是跟你在一起，因为我可能正处于一种爽到断片的阶段。不过当然了，如果你当时在的话，那就太好了。
Where was that? Was it Hollywood Bowl, Will? Hollywood Bowl, yeah. Oh, right, okay. Well, while we're on the subject of that, can you whisper to us when we might be able to see you live again? Which?
那是哪儿？是好莱坞露天剧场吗，威尔？好莱坞露天剧场，对。哦，对了，好吧。既然说到这儿，能不能悄悄告诉我们，我们什么时候还能再看到你们的现场演出？哪个？
So Radiohead, when do you think we might hear a new album or see you live again? Again, something I was going to use you into, but let's get into it. No idea. You can't even whisper. Really, no idea. Well, we like to tour when we have new songs
所以是电台司令，你觉得我们什么时候能听到新专辑或再次看到你们的现场演出？又来了，我本想顺着这个话题引入，不过咱们直接开始吧。不知道。你连悄悄话都不能说吗？真的，完全不知道。嗯，我们喜欢在有新歌的时候去巡演，
and we only have new songs when we make a new record and we only seem to make a record in increasingly blue moons. So who knows. Smile. Smile is you're close to finishing that. That new single you guys released the other day was incredible to hear.
而我们只有在做新唱片时才会有新歌，而且我们似乎只有在千载难逢的情况下才会做一张唱片。所以谁知道呢。Smile。Smile乐队，你们快完成那个了吗？你们前几天发的那首新单曲听起来真是不可思议。
Thank you. Yeah, that's pretty much, there was a bit of a delay while we... What was I doing? I was actually trying to do the artwork. I was trying to do the pictures of all the things to delay a record. That is the first time that's been the thing.
谢谢。对，差不多是这样，中间耽搁了一会儿，因为我们……我当时在做什么？我其实在尝试做专辑封面。我一直在尝试画所有东西的图片，以此来拖延一张唱片的发行。这还是第一次发生这种事。
So all the songs are done with that and you're just working on the artwork for the album? It's pretty much done. I think I even have a title, but I'm going to tell you what that is yet. That's taken a long time. It's all taken a long time. I think it's partly just not being able to see each other
所以所有的歌都录完了，你们只是在做专辑的封面？差不多完成了。我想我甚至连名字都起好了，但我还不打算告诉你们是什么。这花了很长时间。这一切都花了很长时间。我想一部分原因只是无法常见面，
for prolonged periods of time, being told to stay indoors. I do a bunch of great research on Wikipedia and I think the one thing they did say is that, or implied is that smile was maybe kind of a COVID baby. Was it something that you guys put... Like this podcast for us was just us just trying to communicate while we're separated.
长期待在一起，被告知要待在室内。我在维基百科上做了一些很棒的研究，我想他们说的一件事，或者暗示的一件事是，Smile可能有点像新冠疫情期间的产物。这是你们弄的……就像这个播客对我们来说只是我们在隔离期间试图交流的方式一样。
Is that how smile came about? Well, in actual fact, no. It came about really, really quickly and then painfully long. We got into a studio and Johnny and Tom had already... It felt like they'd like tracked about four things before I even knew what was going on. And then sort of lockdown happened surely after...
Smile就是这样诞生的吗？嗯，实际上，不是的。它的诞生非常非常快，然后是痛苦的漫长。我们走进录音室，强尼和汤姆已经……感觉在我还没弄明白怎么回事之前，他们就已经录好了大约四首东西。然后没过多久就封城了……
This is the drummer. Tom Skinner, yeah. Got you. And then I was left with what we'd recorded on tape, which was fine, really fun to go on to tape again. And then I was sat there trying to puzzle out the lyrics for a very long time, locked in a house. And then it got sort of protracted and protracted.
这位是鼓手。汤姆·斯金纳，对。明白了。然后我留下了我们录在磁带上的东西，这挺好的，重新用磁带录音真的很有趣。然后我坐在那儿，在家里被隔离了很长时间，绞尽脑汁地想歌词。接着这事就一拖再拖，拖了又拖。
It was deeply frustrating, but it's been the same for everybody. I have to figure out a way to record vocals over the internet straight into Nigel's studio. That was pretty wild. Wow. So I was kind of virtually into the studio. Did you do that like on an ISDN
这让人无比沮丧，但对每个人来说都一样。我必须想办法通过互联网将人声直接录制到奈杰尔的录音室里。那真是相当疯狂。哇。所以我相当于虚拟进入了录音室。你们是用ISDN做的吗，
or like on Source Connect? Yeah, Source Connect in there. But anything after four o'clock, forget it, because that's when the kids get home from school. Yeah, that's it. Yeah, same. I have to stop. Is that an atypical way for you guys to make music
还是用Source Connect？对，就是那里的Source Connect。不过下午四点以后就算了吧，因为那是孩子们放学回家的时间。对，就是这样。对，一样。我得停下来。对你们来说，这种制作音乐的方式是非典型的吗，
where the music happens first and then the lyrics, I apologize, I bet you get this question a lot. I've actually asked it a few times to musicians. And the consensus is that it's a little of each. Sometimes it's music first, sometimes it's lyrics first. Or is there one you prefer? Is there like a set, you know what? I really, really want to focus on lyrics first.
就是音乐先创作出来，然后才有歌词，抱歉，我打赌你们经常听到这个问题。我其实已经问过音乐人好几次了。大家的共识是各占一半。有时是音乐先行，有时是歌词先行。或者你们更喜欢哪一种？有没有一种固定的，你知道吗？我真的，真的很想先专注于歌词？
Because I always find that fascinating too. Just the birth of a song. Well, yeah, it does depend. I think Johnny had come with a bunch of ideas and I hadn't seen him for a while. So they all just came pouring out before I could go, wait, wait, wait. Yeah.
因为我也觉得这总是很迷人。仅仅是一首歌的诞生。嗯，是的，这确实取决于情况。我想强尼带了一堆想法过来，而且我有一段时间没见到他了。所以它们一下子涌了出来，我都来不及说“等等，等等，等等”。对。
So there was a lot of me sort of retrospectively going, okay, what am I going to do with that? Which was really nice. It was a really, like a challenge for me. And then there are other ones, like the one we released last week, you will never work in television again. Yeah.
所以有很多时间我都在事后琢磨，好吧，我该怎么处理这些？这真的很棒。对我和说这是一个真正的挑战。然后还有其他的，比如我们上周发的那首《你再也不会在电视里工作了》。对。
My Lord. My Lord to Sean Hayes. Yeah. Was that pointed at Sean? Yeah. How did you guys know about Sean's future? Like how did you? I don't think it's unique to Sean.
天哪。对肖恩·海耶斯的赞美。对。那是针对肖恩的吗？对。你们怎么知道肖恩的未来的？你们是怎么……我不认为这只针对肖恩。
How did you guys, how did you guys, do you guys remember writing your first song? Like how did that go? First ever. Yeah, first ever. Like was it music for like that? How did it, I don't know, how did it, how did you go like, hey, we've written a song?
你们怎么，你们怎么，你们还记得写第一首歌时的情景吗？那是怎样的？生平第一首。对，生平第一首。那是不是类似于音乐……那是怎么，我不知道，你们是怎么说，嘿，我们写了一首歌？
You know what I mean? I remember writing one way out, it was 11 called Mushroom Cloud. But I can only remember half the riff now, and none of the lyrics. But then Johnny, I remember Johnny and I, like we borrowed a four track off someone,
你知道我的意思吗？我记得写过一首，那是11岁时写的一首叫《蘑菇云》。但我现在只能记住半段吉他Riff，歌词全忘了。不过后来强尼，我记得强尼和我，我们借了别人的四轨录音机，
went round to his mom's house. Was this at, what is it, Abingdon School where you guys all met? Yeah. Yes. And the band was on a Friday because guys, that was when they decided to record, right? Wait, back to the songwriting thing.
去了他妈妈家。这是在，叫什么来着，你们大家相遇的阿宾顿学校吗？对。是的。那个乐队叫“在星期五”，因为伙计们，那是他们决定录音的时候，对吧？等等，回到写歌这件事上。
Do you guys ever, because I do this sometimes, I'll be dreaming the most incredible like lick or lyrics or something. Not that I write music, but I'm like, wow, that's amazing. I can't wait to wake up. I'm gonna remember it.
你们有没有过——因为我有时会这样——在梦里梦到最不可思议的旋律或歌词之类的。倒不是说我写音乐，但我就觉得，哇，太棒了。我等不及要醒来了。我会记住它的。
And of course I never remember it. Have you ever dreamt a song and actually remembered it and then wrote it? Bits. Bits. Bits of it. But it's never, it's almost, it's always slightly underwhelming. Not quite as genius as you thought it was
当然我从来没记住过。你们有没有梦到过一首歌，而且真的记住了，然后把它写了下来？片段。片段。其中的片段。但它从来没有，它几乎，它总是有点让人失望。并没有你刚醒来时想象的那么天才。
at that moment just before you woke up. I actually know, I know the story of these two musicians whom we all know and revere and we've been doing it a long time. And I'm not gonna name drop them because I called out for it. I will later. But they, one of them called up the other one
其实我知道，我知道这两个音乐人的故事，我们所有人都认识并尊敬他们，而且他们已经做这一行很久了。我不会点他们的名，因为我是为了这个才提的。我待会儿会说。但是他们，其中一个给另一个打电话，
and said, what's been going on? And he said, oh man, I just, I took mushrooms last night and I had the most genius ideas and I wrote them all down. Hang on, let me go get it. So he came back and he's like, I've written down this incredible epiphany
说，最近怎么样？那个人说，哦，天哪，我，我昨晚吃了迷幻蘑菇，我有了最天才的想法，我都记下来了。等等，我去拿过来。所以他回来后说，我写下了这个不可思议的顿悟，
and he starts to read it to himself and he goes, what did it say? And then he goes, no, it's total rubbish. He was so excited. He thought like, yeah, what's that like, Tom? You wake up and you roll over and you just start dictating a lyric or tune into your iPhone
然后他开始读给自己听，接着他说，这写的是什么？然后他说，不，这完全是垃圾。他当时太兴奋了。他心想，对，汤姆，那是怎样一种体验？你醒来，翻个身，然后开始把歌词或曲调口述到你的iPhone里，
and your wife rolls over next to you and says, oh, he's come up with another idea. She's a very sound sleeper, happily. There you go. But actually phones are convenient because they have their own lights. So you can literally wake up at three o'clock in the morning, start scribbling and then go back to sleep
而你妻子在你旁边翻了个身说，哦，他又想出一个主意了。她睡眠很沉，真好。你看。不过其实手机很方便，因为它们自带灯光。所以你可以大半夜三点醒来，开始胡乱涂鸦，然后继续睡觉，
or much of something which I do frequently. I mean, I have pretty much given up using an actual physical notebook now. Yeah. Which is weird for me. Digitally. Yeah, yeah. So the coming together of all of these ideas
或者哼唱一些东西，我经常这么做。我的意思是，我几乎已经放弃使用真正的实体笔记本了。对。这对我来说很奇怪。数字化。对，对，对。所以所有这些灵感的汇集，
for a song, you know, you guys have consistently been so sort of forward moving with your sound, with the progression of your sound of your band and you challenge the audience to kind of get with different time and all that stuff. I would assume that the moment you hear
为了创作一首歌，你知道的，你们的音乐风格一直都在不断向前发展，乐队风格不断演变，你们挑战听众去适应不同的节拍等等。我想，当你听到乐队里任何人提出的这个新想法，当你们把它们引入并构建出一首歌时，那种惊讶和（以一种好的方式）不适的感觉，对你们来说一定和我们听众是一样的。当我们第一次听到它时，
this new idea from any one of your bandmates as you guys introduce them into and building a song out, that moment of surprise and maybe discomfort in a good way has got to be the same for you as it is for us, the audience. When we first hear it,
那么，当你听到强尼带着某种听起来完全诡异的东西进来，用他正在研究的这些新乐器之一，或者你，汤姆，用钢琴、歌词或其他什么东西带进来时，这个过程是怎样的？在决定它是否合适之前，你会给它多少时间？换句话说，我会把一首歌听30遍，
so what is that process like when you hear Johnny come in with something that sounds totally bizarre with one of these new instruments that he's working on or you, Tom, will bring it in with the piano or Lyric or something like that. How much time do you give it before you decide whether it's a fit or not? In other words, I'll listen to a song 30 times
然后才会想，哦，天哪，这是我最喜欢的歌。因为确实如此，很少是在第一遍就……我的意思是，你们的节奏实在是太美妙的非典型了。当你们开始将所有这些不同的想法融合进歌曲中时，对你们来说这个过程是怎样的？强尼，你想试试回答这个吗？哇。
before I'm like, oh my God, this is my favorite song ever. Because it does, it's rarely on the first one. I mean, you guys are so beautifully atypical with your rhythms. What's that process for you guys as you start to meld all of these different ideas into songs? Johnny, you want to try that one? Wow.
抱歉。我们马上回来。在那之后我们不得不去休息一下。你在开玩笑吧，贝特曼？我知道，我知道。该死的。这对我和说意义重大，威尔。强尼和汤姆都在这儿。
Sorry. We'll be right back. We have to take a fucking break after that. Are you fucking kidding me, Bateman? I know, I know. Jesus fucking. This is a big one for me, Will. Johnny and Tom are here.
我想这大概跟数字有关。强尼刚刚喝完他的第四杯啤酒。好歌。在这个回答进行到一半时我可能会觉得无聊，但我还是会试一试。我会保持清醒的，强尼。你和我。谢谢你，强尼。
I think it was something about numbers. Johnny just finished his fourth beer. Great song. I'm going to be bored halfway through this answer, but I'm going to go for it. I'll stay awake, Johnny. You and me. Thank you, Johnny.
我知道。谢谢你的坦诚。哇。他刚才问什么来着？他甚至都不知道。当你听到奇怪的东西时，你需要花多长时间来决定它是奇怪还是伟大？嗯，这很奇怪，我想这些年来几十年来，
I know. Thank you for your candor. Wow. What did he ask again? He doesn't even know. When you hear weird stuff, how long do you take to decide whether it's weird or great? Well, it's odd because I think over the years and decades,
我们已经学会了去相信当你听到某些听起来毫无意义的东西时的直觉，比如《Everything in Its Right Place》的早期录音，那是《Kid A》的第一首歌。那听起来就像是一种奇异的噪音。这不会是一首歌，但果不其然，过了一两天，它突然变成了这件神奇的事情。
we've kind of learned to trust when you hear something that just sounds senseless, like the early takes of everything in its right place, which is the first song on Kadei. And that just sounded like a bizarre noise. And this isn't going to be a song, but sure enough, after a day or two, it suddenly becomes this magical thing.
顺便说一句，大约六个月。对。强尼，你有没有过这样的时刻，当你进来时——就像杰森刚才说的，我们在做的事情中也会发生这种情况——感觉就像是，好吧，剧本在这儿。这就是你要做的。每个人都知道自己的角色。
About six months, by the way. Yeah. Do you have those moments like, Johnny, where you do, so when you come in, kind of to what Jason was saying, and this happens in what we do too, where it's like, okay, well, here's the script. Here's what you're going to do. Everybody knows their role.
你有点像是走进来。然后当你开始做时，奇迹发生了。事情发生了。有人用不同的方式做某事。有人以你意料之外的方式说了一句话。然后你最后发现了一个小段子。你最终发现了一个时刻。你发现了一个笑话。
You kind of come in. And then as you do it, magic happens. Something happens. Somebody does something a different way. Somebody says something a way that you didn't. And then you end up finding like a bit. You end up finding a moment. You find a joke.
你发现了一些能让它升华的东西。然后你们互相对视一眼。当一切结束时，你们会有种，哦，那真是，太酷了。是的。我的意思是，你，我想这就是你所希望的所有创意材料，希望总和大于部分，你知道的，更伟大。是的。
You find something that kind of elevates it. And you kind of look at each other. And when it's over, you kind of like, oh, that was fucking, that was cool. Yeah. I mean, you're, I think that's all the creative stuff you're hoping for the sum of the parts to be, you know, greater. Yeah.
当事情一起发生时，它就是那种整体性的，你知道的，格式塔的东西。如果我可以借用这个难听的词的话。当然可以。我能不能快速问一下，你们在这里做什么？就像，你知道的，是因为……对，你们为什么要答应来？是因为你们听过这个播客并且喜欢它？
When things happen together, it's the whole sort of, you know, gestality thing. If I can use that gruesome word. Sure. Can I just ask real quickly, what are you guys doing here? Like, you know, is it because... Yeah, why did you say yes to this? Is it because you've listened to the podcast and you like it?
A，B，你们的经纪人逼你们来的？还是C，你们在百老汇看过肖恩演的《承诺，承诺》，然后就只是想跟他混在一起？你们能看出我对肖恩完全入迷了吗？那是唯一一张我在看的照片。直到你开口我们才看出来……哦，好吧，我想说……你知道吗？
A, B, your manager made you do it. Or C, you saw Sean on Broadway and promises, promises. And you just wanted to hang out with him. Can you tell that I've totally seemed in on Sean? That's the only picture I'm looking at. We couldn't tell until you... Oh, well, I want to say... You know what?
抽个号吧。这不是谁都能想要的。汤姆和强尼，我想问问你们受过哪些影响。因为你们，当你们刚推出我所知道的第一张唱片时，它立刻就成了那种——我认为这对我来说是一个真正伟大的乐队的标志，我不是故意要让你难堪——当你有那种感觉，你会说，
Take a number. It's not anybody wants it. Tom and Johnny, I wanted to ask you guys about your influences. Because you, when you guys first came out with your first record that I was aware of, it immediately was one of those, I think it's the hallmark of a really great band to me. And I don't mean to embarrass you, when you have that thing where you go,
哦，我真的很喜欢这个声音。我觉得我，我觉得我熟悉这个声音。它感觉既新颖又同时非常熟悉，因为它有点像，我总是说音乐能抓痒抓到你甚至不知道自己有的那个痒点。我一直对电台司令的音乐有这种感觉。我不知道，你们成长过程中听的人是谁，比如在高中时，
oh, I really like this sound. I feel like I've, I feel like I know this sound. Like it feels new and simultaneously very familiar because it's sort of, I always say music that scratches the niche that you didn't know you had in a way. And I always felt that way about Radiohead's music. And I don't know, who are the guys that you, and people that you listen to growing up like in high school
有哪些乐队是你们觉得，你们简直无法……有哪些唱片是你听个没完的？比如对我来说，从1983年到1989年，我听The Smiths（史密斯乐队）听个没完。我就是停不下来。现在还在听。对，现在还在听。
and who are the bands that you were like, you just couldn't... What were the records you couldn't stop playing? Like for me, I couldn't stop playing the Smiths from 1983 to 1989. I could not stop playing the Smiths. Still playing them. Yeah, still playing them.
我女儿现在也在听，我太喜欢了。我的意思是，我想对我们来说，是，你知道的，Pixies（小精灵乐队）、New Order（新秩序乐队）。Sonic Youth（索尼克青年乐队）。诸如此类的乐队，对。我的意思是，波士顿乐队，我们一直这么叫它们。我们迷恋Throwing Muses，还有……天哪，Throwing Muses是个伟大的乐队。你们对非典型乐器的喜好，
My daughter's now playing them and I'm loving it. I mean, I suppose for us it was, you know, Pixies, New Order. Sonic Youth. Bands like that, yeah. I mean, the Boston Bands, we kept calling them. We were into throwing muses and, you know... Oh God, throwing muses is a great band. And did your attraction to atypical instruments
是不是源于你们的父亲让你们早年接触了古典音乐？还是说，这也是我从互联网上听到的东西，因为我是个古典音乐迷？所以你们对所有这些其他乐器的开放态度，是那种早期播下的种子吗？我青少年时期的幻想就是不断开车经过
come from your early exposure to classical music from your dad? Again, some of the stuff that I thought I picked up here on the internet listening to it, because I'm a big classical music fan. And so your sort of openness to all these other instruments, was that part of that early seeding? My adolescent fantasy was constantly driving past
乐器行，幻想着能进去买一件乐器。这仅仅是关于能够买任何乐器。这无关收集吉他或键盘之类的东西。就好像，想象一下能够走进去直接买一把单簧管或手风琴。那该有多棒？这正是我的生活现在的样子。
the music shop and wishing I could go in there and buy an instrument. And it was about just being able to buy any instrument. It wasn't about collecting guitars or keyboards or something. It was like, imagine just being able to go in and just buy a clarinet or buy a accordion. Wouldn't that be amazing? And that's sort of how my life is panned out now.
我确实在收集这类东西，我只是发现……因为你喜欢它们能发出的所有不同声音，以及这如何创造出一种……仅仅是一种频谱……对我来说，这一切都是技术。只是有些比较旧。你知道的，钢琴比穆格合成器更古老，
I do collect these kind of things and I just find... Because you love all the different sounds that they can make and how that kind of creates a sort of like a... Just a spectrum of... I mean, to me it's all technology. Just some of it is older. You know, a piano is older technology than a MOOC and everything,
但它仍然是某人的创意，是一种制作音乐的方式。那么，你们所有人被技术和电子产品能为传统乐器声音带来的增强和丰富所吸引，这纯属巧合吗？还是你们其中一人率先开始了这一点，并帮助乐队的其他成员融入并接受了它？我想有一点……我们刚开始时……我们是一个坐着面包车到处巡演的小乐队。而且……
but it's still somebody's idea and it's a way of making music. And then was it a coincidence that you guys all became attracted to what technology and electronics can do to enhance and augment all the sort of traditional sounds of instruments? Or did one of you sort of start with that and kind of help the rest of the band
谁在开车？其实我们轮流开。我倒不常开，因为我通常在后面喝醉了。不，汤姆。大多是乐队里比较负责任的成员。那是谁？我能猜猜吗？菲尔、埃德或是蒂姆，我们饱受折磨的巡演经理。事情是这样的……我想基本上发生的情况是我们都交换了各自听得很多的东西，我想随着岁月的流逝，
incorporate that and embrace that? I think there was a little bit of... When we first started it was... We were a small band travelling around in a van. And... Who was driving? Actually, we took turns. Me not often because I was usually drunk in the back.
我们开始听不同的东西，开始分享莫里康内的音乐，看库布里克的电影，听电子音乐，发现德国摇滚，发现Can乐队，发现这个，发现那个。而强尼一直都是……那个多乐器演奏家，可以拿起绝对任何东西，
No, Tom. Mostly the more responsible members of the band. Who was that? Can I guess? Phil, Ed or Tim are long suffering tour manager. And it was like... I think basically what happened was we all swapped what we were listening to a lot and I think as the years went on
包括竖笛。而且……对，我……然后我们有了自己的录音室，所以我们可以买设备并学习如何使用它。这很令人兴奋。跟我讲讲你们在巴士、在面包车里听了多少发电厂乐队（Kraftwerk）的音乐？哈。大概还不够。
we started listening to different things, started sharing Morricone, watching Kubrick films, Kubrick films, listening to electronic music, discovering crowd rock, discovering can, discovering this, discovering that. And Johnny was always... The multi-instrumentalist could pick up absolutely anything
我的意思是，你知道的，我们简直是在研究《Computer World》那张专辑，大家一起听，讨论里面在发生什么以及为什么。太棒了。而且为什么……我们几乎可以列出每一种乐器是什么，他们是怎么做每一个……尤其是因为他们有一次来南美巡演时。
including recorder. And... Yeah, I... And then we had our own studio so we could buy equipment and learn how to use it. And that was exciting. Tell me about how much craft work you guys listen to
不会吧！我们和他们共进了一顿非常漫长、持久的晚餐，我们在那儿基本上解剖了整张专辑，询问每一首作品里用了哪种乐器以及什么设备。不会吧！这可以说是终极极客行为了。太棒了。哇。
on the bus in the van. Huh. Not enough, probably. I mean, you know, we literally study Computer World, that album, in terms of playing it to each other and discussing what's going on and why. It's so good.
这有没有给你们提供一个彻底终结对话的开场白，比如走到他们这些甜心面前，然后说，嗨，拉尔夫，我们都很怕你。我就是这么开始这次采访的，该死。你可没法从那儿继续下去了。没法继续。没法继续了。我们马上回来。
And why sort of... We can pretty much list what every instrument was and how they did every... And especially because they came on tour of this to South America once. No! And we had a very long, prolonged dinner with them where we basically dissected the whole record and asked which instrument
现在，回到节目中。对你们来说，库布里克的影响是什么？仅仅是他贯穿电影使用古典音乐的方式，以及那种力量、宏大，与其中一些画面的并置吗？就是这个，他对我来说就是这样。是的。在《闪灵》里是彭德雷茨基（Pendericki）的音乐。
and what was used on every single piece of that. No way! Which was the ultimate geek out. That's great. Wow. Did it give them a completely conversation-killing opener by going out to them, such as their sweet people
那是一个非常巨大的影响。但我记得第一次看《闪灵》时，通过那种方式在一种更深的情感层面上产生了联系。而且它当时也刚好很契合我们在做《OK Computer》时的状态。你知道的，还有莫里康内。突然之间，我记得当我们做那个的时候，
and saying, Hi Ralph, we're all very scared of you. That's how I started this interview, damn it. You can't move on from that. You can't. You can't. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
强尼，你还记得我们为《OK Computer》弄弦乐的时候吗？对。那些乐手是我们遇到过脾气最暴躁的乐手。绝对是的。还记得吗？你当时直冒汗。对。因为他们就像是，看了一眼
What was the Kubrick influence for you guys? Was it just his way to use classical music throughout his films and the power, the majesty of that, juxtaposed with some of those images? Was that, that does it for me with him? Yeah. It was a pender-resky thing in The Shining.
你写的东西，然后就想，哦，天哪。我记得。是的，我记得。真的吗？管弦乐队的图书管理员警告过我，他说，别试着套近乎，别用那张专辑，因为他们根本没有。
It was a really massive one. But I remember seeing The Shining for the first time and making the connection on a sort of deeper emotional level through that. And it just sort of seemed to fit where we were at with OK Computer as well at the time. You know, I did Morricone. There's suddenly this, I remember when we did that,
对。等等，强尼，那是你开始考虑自己做配乐的时候吗？你们俩都做过配乐。还有汤姆的《阴风阵阵》。还有汤姆。太棒了。对。
Johnny, you remember when we did the strings for OK Computer? Yeah. And those players were the grumpiest players we've ever had. For sure. Remember that? You were sweating. Yeah. Because they were like, they just took one look
我不识谱。这家伙才是搞这个的人。我确信我没说错。强尼？我的意思是，这只是一种感觉，当我们在学校时，我们听各种各样的音乐，而且我们当时还不够成熟，不会害怕去尝试并心想，是的，我们可以做到。
at what you wrote and they were like, oh, God. I remember that. Yeah, I do remember. Really? The orchestra librarian warned me and he said, don't try and engage, don't use the album because they don't have any.
你知道的，就像我们听一首史密斯乐队的歌，然后想，好吧，我们也来试试那种风格。但后来你会听别人的音乐，甚至是古典音乐。这一切都让人觉得，为什么还要害怕雄心勃勃而不敢去尝试呢。而且，我也觉得我们从来没有像其他人那样真正看到过其中的区别。
Yeah. Wait, Johnny, was that when you started getting into thinking about scoring yourself? You both scored. And Tommy suspires. And Tom. Awesome. Yeah.
不过，你现在觉得没那么害怕了吗？我正想说，你觉得，你知道的，那就是年轻的美妙之处对吧？你会想，管他呢，为什么不是我？为什么我不试试？然后随着年龄增长，你开始知道，我不知道，我对这一点有两种看法。比如，我是知道自己的局限性，还是我根本不在乎？
I can't read music. This guy's the man who does it. I'm sure I haven't said it. Johnny? I mean, it's just that thing that when we were at school, we listened to all this kind of music and we weren't old enough to be scared of trying it and thinking, yeah, we could do that.
我想另一个麻烦是，你会开始认出那些在那种音乐中，或者可能在表演中，或者以你所向往的风格创作的人。一旦你知道该怎么做，你就会开始认出那些真正能做到并且在这方面极其厉害的人。那就是你会稍微退缩一步，心想，
You know, so the same way we listened to a Smith song and think, well, let's try and do that kind of thing. But then you'd listen to other people's music, even classical stuff. And it all felt like, why be scared of being overambitious and just trying to. But also, I don't think we never really saw the difference in the same way other people do.
是的，这远远超出了我所能……但这也意味着你只是，你知道的，你在瞄准却没射中，不过瞄准本身就很有趣，对吧？但那里的任务不同，对吧？为电影配乐，我的意思是，你被要求，你大部分时间都在看画面。我不知道你们是不是这样，
Do you feel less scared now, though? I was going to say, do you feel, you know, that sort of, that's one of the great things about youth, right? You're like, well, fuck, why not me? Why don't I try it? And then as you get older, you start to know, I don't know, I can kind of go both ways on this. Like, do I know my limitations or I also don't care?
或者你们是怎么和保罗合作的，但你大部分时间都在看着画面，你被要求去支持、衬托或并置影像、故事和场景所表达的内容。你是在支持这一切，这与制作一首歌或一张唱片不同，那是一件独立的娱乐作品。
I think the other trouble is you start to recognize people who are doing in that music or perhaps acting or whatever in that style that you aspire to. And once you know how to sort of do it, you get to recognize people who can really do it and are amazing at it. And that's the moment where you kind of, you retreat a little bit and think,
所以，你喜欢这个过程中的不同之处吗？我只是把它当成还在组乐队，只不过多了一个导演、一个剧本和一位摄影师。你只是其中的一部分。而且，就像我们之前讨论的那样，你希望它能汇聚成更好的东西，让电影看起来更好，
yeah, this is so way beyond anything I could have. But you know, it just means you're kind of, you know, you're aiming and missing, but it's fun to aim, right? But the task is different there, right? With scoring a film, I mean, you're being asked to, you're looking at picture for the most part. I don't know if you guys did it the same way
电影会让音乐比原本更好，最终它们会结合成某种改进的作品。嗯，还有，我认为最好的电影音乐是两者之间留有一定空间。我的意思是，要做那种具有指令性、对银幕上看到的内容作出反应的电影音乐非常容易，但我讨厌那样。这让我发疯。
or how you work with Paul, but you're looking, for the most part, you're looking at picture and you're being asked to either support, frame, or juxtapose what the image is, what the story is, what the scene is about. And you're there in support of, effectively, that as opposed to making a song or record, it's a standalone piece of entertainment.
这对我来说毫无意义。我的意思是，如果两个演员在舞台上相对而立，其中一个人只是在模仿另一个人的动作或呼应它们，那这就毫无意义。你们应该产生化学反应。而且，以我有限的经验，我发现非常有趣的是，观众会建立起你未必有意的联系，
So is it, do you enjoy the difference in that process? I just treat it as being in a band still, just with, you know, a director and a script and a cinematographer. And you're sort of, you're just one part of it. And again, it's like we talked about earlier, you hope that it's going to add up to a better thing and it's going to make the film look better
所以你往往会发现，有些东西在风格上可能感觉跨度有点大，但当你把它放进一个场景中时，它会比那种对场景机械反应的东西强大得多。真搞笑。这让我想起你在埃克塞特上大学时去你家。当时有这么个风潮，不知为何，
and the film will make the music better than it is and it'll just combine it to something that's an improvement. Well, also, I think the best film music is where there's a bit of a stretch between the two. I mean, it's very easy to do film music that's prescriptive, that's reacting to what you're seeing on the screen, but I hate that. It drives me mad.
电视一直开着，声音是关着的，而唱片一直在放。只要有任何图像配上任何音乐，就会产生某种效果，而且通常是极好的效果。也就是在那时我开始迷上视频剪辑。在艺术学院里，我转向了视频制作，并发现你可以把任何东西剪辑到任何东西上去。并且彻底改变它的含义，对吧。
It makes no sense to me. I mean, if you're two actors standing opposite each other on stage and one person is just imitating the movements of another or echoing them, there's no point in that. You should be bouncing it off. And also, what I find very interesting in my limited experience is the fact that the viewer will make connections that you don't necessarily intend,
对，我发现视频剪辑可以像剪辑声音一样，因为你的脑海会在它们本不存在的地方寻找联系。你这么说真有意思，威尔，如果这不是一个后续的话题的话。这就是，这就是个后续。嘿，伙计，我知道你是嘉宾，但给其他人留点时间。
so that you oftentimes like something that could feel a bit of a stretch stylistically when you put it in a scene can be so much more powerful than somebody that's reacting to the scene. That's funny. That reminds me of going to your house when you were at college in Exeter. And there was that thing of the craze was, for some reason,
别让我把这只小狗噎着。谢谢。别把小狗噎着。所以我昨晚在看我提到的那部丹麦剧《谋杀》，顺便说一句，我能说这个吗？这部分会被剪掉的，对吧？对，对。我能说这个吗？
the TV was on the whole time with the sound down and there were records going on all the time. And just the tradition of almost any image and any music just does something and often does a great thing. That's when I started getting into video editing. In the art college, I'd moved to doing video and discovered that you can cut anything to anything. And completely change the meaning of it, yeah.
我想，哦，一共12集。太好了。所以我到了……最后一集时我熬夜了。带我们回顾一下你的夜晚。这太棒了。我女朋友睡着了。孩子们睡着了。太棒了。
Yeah, I discovered video editing can be like cutting sound in the sense that your mind will look for connections when they're not there. It's funny you say that. I have a follow-up, Will, if this isn't a follow-up. It is, it is a follow-up. Hey, man, I know that you're a guest, but give everybody else a second.
然后它结束了，我抬头一看，心想，不，不，不，一共有20集。所以我熬夜了。好一个故事。但我的意思是，我的意思是，我看了这一场戏，配乐进来了。顺便说一句，里面的音乐其实真的很好，但有一个非常——这发生在昨晚。
Don't let me choke the puppy. Thank you. Don't choke the puppy. So I was watching that Danish show that I mentioned, The Killing Last Night, which, by the way, can I just say this? This thing edited out, isn't it? Yeah, yeah. Can I just say this?
这个时刻出现了，这个角色登场了，她正要透露点什么。音乐进来了，但完全不对劲。这是很久以来我第一次觉得它完全——然后场景就结束了。我在想，这他妈是怎么回事？是不是有人漏了什么？到底有多少人看这个的时候没发现这一点？
I thought like, oh, it's 12 episodes. Great. So I got, I was like, the last episode I stayed up late. Walk us through your night. This is great. My girlfriend fell asleep. The kids are asleep. It was great.
太诡异了。音乐引领你从情感上走过整个场景，以及它为你衔接下一个场景等，这有多重要……是的，这是成败的关键。你们是怎么认识保罗·托马斯·安德森的？是你们主动联系他的吗？
And then it ended and I looked up and I said, no, no, no, there are 20 episodes. So I stayed up. What a story. But my point was, my point was I watched this scene and the score came in. And by the way, the music's actually really good in it, but there was a very, this happened last night.
还是他联系你们？你们是偶然碰到的吗？我的意思是，那是……那是很久以前的事了，强尼。你还记得吗？我想我们当时在洛杉矶录制《Amnesiac》。他邀请我们去参加《恋爱鸡尾酒》的演职员内部放映，部分原因是他从汤姆的一首歌里借用了片名。
This moment comes up and this character comes in and she's about to reveal something. And the music comes in and it was totally wrong. It was the first time in a long time where I felt like it was completely, and then the scene ended. And I thought, what the fuck was that? Did somebody like leave a scam? How many people that went through that didn't catch that?
我直到到了放映现场才意识到这一点。我当时想，等一下。这太棒了。然后他来到录音室，有点像……我的意思是，我可以这么说吗，用英国口音瞎混？这听起来很糟糕吗？英国口音。
It was so bizarre. And how important it is to taking you through, emotionally through the scene and where it leaves you for the next scene, et cetera. It was... Yeah, it's make or break. How did you guys meet Paul Thomas Anderson? Did you reach out to him?
你要不要也戴顶棒球帽来凑齐全套？不。不。没有什么比戴着棒球帽的英国人更糟糕的了。哦。甚至连“瞎混”这个词都让我直冒汗。我知道。太尴尬了。
Did he reach out to you? Did you guys bump into each other? I mean, that's just... It was a long time ago, Johnny. Can you remember? I think we were recording Health of the Thief in Los Angeles. And he invited us to the cast and crew screening of Punch Truck Love, partly because he'd taken the title
除了保罗，我觉得大概有20年没有人来我们录音室瞎混过了。尽管必须指出的是，英国人……使用“chill”或“chill out”这个词简直让人筋疲力尽。不。这是最糟的。伙计，我只是要在周末放松一下。强尼，让他请你来给电影配乐，是不是像拔牙一样难？
from one of Tom's songs. I didn't realise that till we got to the screening. I was like, wait a minute. And that was great. And then he came to the studio and was sort of... I mean, can I say, hanging out in an English accent? Was that sounding awful? British accent.
嗯，我的意思是，他只是……他拿了一个粉丝制作的盗版古典音乐合辑——那是我写的——然后把它配到画面上觉得挺喜欢，就说，你能做出更多这样的音乐吗？我当时对电影并不太了解，这只是一个能和管弦乐队一起演奏的借口，而那才是最大的爽点。现在依然如此。
Do you want to wear a baseball cap as well, just to complete it? No. No. Nothing worse than an Englishman in a baseball cap. Oh. Even hanging out has made me literally sweat. I know. It was embarrassing.
太棒了。大约那个时候他在一家酒店里朝我走来。在伦敦。我碰到了他。我说，我要把你的朋友借走一会儿。是吗？他说，别让他走。对。
I don't think we've had anyone hang out in our studio, except for Paul for about 20 years. Although it has to be noted that the English... The use of the term chill or chill out is exhausting. No. It's the worst. Mate, just going to chill out for the weekend. Johnny, was it pulling teeth for him to get you to score a film?
太霸道了。这很疯狂，但我理解。我为网飞做过一个节目，我多年来一直想和Pavement乐队的斯蒂芬·马尔穆斯（Stephen Malkmus）合作。我想，我怎么才能……所以我写了这个节目，我们字面意义上写了所有这些场景，虽然我当时甚至还不知道音乐会是什么，
Well, I mean, he just... So he took a fan bootleg of this classical thing I'd written and just put it up to the picture and liked it and said, can you do more music like this? And I didn't really know about him or about films or it was just like an excuse to have an orchestra to play with and that was the biggest kick. It still is.
但我知道斯蒂芬会……然后我打电话联系他并见了他，问你愿意……就是那种感觉，我必须拥有……我相信保罗也有过同样的感受，那就是，他的音乐极大地启发了我，并在我们创作正在做的事情的过程中发挥了巨大的作用。
It's amazing. He came up to me in a hotel around then. In London. I ran into him. I said, I'm going to steal your friend for a bit. Did he? He said, he doesn't let him go. Yeah.
你知道，它虽然不是直接的催化剂，但影响巨大。然后将他的音乐与我们正在做的事情结合起来，把所有的剪辑片段发给他，然后得到反馈，对我来说是一次如此神奇的经历，因为它完美地收尾了。我当时就想，哦，对，它完全按照我想要的方式完成了。尽管音乐对我和来说是崭新的，
It's very abusive. It's crazy, but I get that. I did this show for Netflix and I was like, I really wanted for years, I wanted to do something with Steve Malcomis from Pavement. I was like, how do I... So I wrote this show and we quite literally wrote all these scenes knowing that I didn't even know what the music was yet,
但我会想，是的，每一次都对。是的，完全如此。马尔穆斯太棒了。他真的是少数几个让我真正期待其新专辑的艺术家之一。又有一张Jicks乐队的唱片要出了，我就很兴奋。而且我知道它可能会相当……我不知道，他就是一个伟大的吉他手，
but I knew that Steve was going to... And then I got to call him and meet him and go, would you... It was that thing of like, I just had to have... And I'm sure Paul had the same thing, which is like, I was so inspired by his music and it was played such a huge role in how we wrote the stuff we were doing.
出色的吉他手。就像那种我能一直听下去并心想，这简直太棒了。依然是不可思议的乐器。你们……现在有这些非常受欢迎的纪录片，每个人都在谈论和观看的披头士乐队纪录片。
You know, it wasn't the impetus for it, but it was massive. And then marrying his music with what we were doing and sending him all the cuts and then coming back was such a magical experience for me because it just completed. I was like, oh yeah, it completed exactly the way that I wanted it to. Even though the music was new to me,
你知道，这并不是创作的初衷，但它的影响太巨大了。后来把他的音乐和我们正在做的事情结合起来，把所有的剪辑发给他，然后得到反馈，对我来说是一次非常神奇的体验，因为它圆满了。当时我就觉得，噢，对，它完全按照我想要的方式完成了。尽管这音乐对当时的我来说还很新鲜，
I was like, yes, every time. Yes, exactly. Malcolmus is amazing. He's genuinely one of the few artists whose records I actually look forward to. Another Jicks record coming out, then I get excited. And I know it's going to probably be quite sort of... I don't know, he's just a great guitar player,
我就想，是的，每一次都这样。没错，绝对是这样。马尔科姆·吉克斯太棒了。他是为数不多的、我真的会翘首以盼其新专辑发行的艺术家之一。只要听说Jicks有新专辑要出，我就会很兴奋。而且我知道它大概会非常……怎么说呢，他就是个优秀的吉他手，
wonderful guitar player. Like the one guitarist I can listen to and just think, that's just amazing. Still amazing instrument. Do you guys... There's these really popular docs now, the Beatles doc that everybody's been talking about and watching.
绝佳的吉他手。就像那种我能一直听下去、然后忍不住感叹的吉他手，真是太棒了。乐器依然弹得出神入化。你们有没有……现在有很多非常火的纪录片，比如大家都一直在谈论和观看的那部披头士纪录片。
And I watched the Bee Gees one. I was never a huge fan, but I thought the documentary was just incredible. Nobody's talking about it. Thank you. No, they are actually. Do you guys, like for fans like me and us, what do you think of them?
我还看过比吉斯（Bee Gees）的纪录片。我从来不是他们的超级粉丝，但我觉得那部纪录片简直不可思议。居然没人讨论它。谢谢。不，其实大家都在讨论。你们两个，对于像我这样的粉丝和我们来说，你们是怎么看他们的？
Would you ever do one? Because we would... That would be so fascinating. Unless you've already done one, I'm an idiot and I don't know. There's a great documentary of them on the OK Computer Tour. Oh. Yeah. It's the documentary to end all documentaries in the sense that
你们会考虑拍一部吗？因为我们……那一定超级迷人。除非你们已经拍过了，而我像个白痴一样不知道。他们有一部超棒的纪录片，记录的是《OK Computer》巡演时期。哦。对。那是空前绝后的纪录片，因为
like clearly these people are never going to have a camera shoved in their face again. I never saw that. I didn't know that. It's very sort of asymmetric and perfect. It's really cool to watch. Oh, great, great. Don't say atypical.
很显然这些人再也不会让镜头怼到脸上了。我从没看过那个。我之前不知道。那种剪辑非常非对称而且完美。看这个真的太酷了。哦，太棒了，太棒了。别说非典型。
If you say atypical... No, I said atypical. I switched it. I switched it. I actually started off as a sort of quite a positive idea. It was, hey, let's show people what it's like from the inside. And then it just... It was really full on.
如果你说非典型……不，我说的是非典型。我改口了。我改口了。我其实一开始是抱着一个挺正面的想法去的。就是，嘿，让我们向大家展示一下内部是什么样的。然后它就……真的太全面了。
Like it wasn't as if you just assume you'd forget about their presence at some point, you'd forget, but you never did. They tried to hide them, you could tell. Did you think at that point, did you think or did you hope that you would still be together now at 50? Uh-huh. Like is this good news that you guys are still doing it? Are you loving it as much now as you did then?
就像你不会觉得在某个时刻你会忘掉他们的存在，你会忘记，但你从来没有忘过。他们试图藏起摄像机，你看得出来。你们当时在想，你们当时想过或者希望过你们现在50岁了还能在一起吗？啊哈。就像，你们现在还在坚持是一件好事吗？你们现在对它的热爱还像当年一样吗？
More? Less? I mean, the same things make us excited, which is technology and sounds and learning new stuff. So, yeah, I don't know. I think while the ideas are still, you know, there... Yes, it's all I wanted to do, all I ever wanted to do. So it just feels like I don't understand.
更多了？还是变少了？我是说，让我们兴奋的事物是一样的，也就是科技、声音和学习新东西。所以，是的，我不知道。我觉得只要这些想法还在，你知道的，还在……是的，这是我唯一想做的事，一直以来唯一想做的事。所以这就感觉……我不太明白。
Yeah, never really... What record do you guys... Fuck, I hate this question, but I kind of want to know. Great, hold it for a second. I don't get the sense that you guys are... I don't get the sense that you guys are pressured by having to be new every single album, new sounds and all that stuff.
是的，从来没有真正……你们觉得哪张专辑……操，我讨厌这个问题，但我又有点想知道。太棒了，先别说。我觉得你们不像是……我觉得你们不会因为每张专辑都必须有新意、新的声音以及所有这些东西而感到压力。
Did that sort of healthy level of indifference happen early on and you guys were able to just kind of continue to make new sounds that sound good to you and hopefully the audience will dig it and as a result of that sort of healthy indifference... And when you characterize that indifference as sexy? It's not sexy indifference, it's a healthy indifference. Okay, yeah.
那种健康的冷漠感是不是很早就有了，所以你们能够继续创作出你们觉得好听、希望观众也会喜欢的新声音，而正是这种健康的冷漠感带来的结果……当你把这种冷漠形容为性感的时候？这不是性感的冷漠，这是一种健康的冷漠。好吧，好吧。
So to be honest, we like just challenges. I like challenges. I like trying to find different ways to write lyrics. I like to find different ways to assemble music. I like to learn new instruments exactly like Johnny and it wakes me up in the morning and probably always will unless I, you know, lose my ability to think straight
说实话，我们只是喜欢挑战。我喜欢挑战。我喜欢尝试寻找不同的方式来写歌词。我喜欢寻找不同的方式来组合音乐。我喜欢学习新乐器，就像强尼（Johnny）一样，这让我早晨充满活力，大概会一直如此，除非我，你知道的，失去了正常思考的能力，
because there isn't anything else. There's not like, now we must move into this area like some sort of aesthetic agenda. It's like you're influenced about what you're listening to. I'm always buying new music. I'm always doing that and I'm always, as you can see from the room I'm sitting in, I'm constantly buying things
因为没有别的东西了。不是说，现在我们必须像某种美学议程那样进入这个领域。这就像你受你正在听的东西的影响。我一直在买新音乐。我一直都在这么做，而且就像你从我坐的这个房间里看到的那样，我一直在买东西，
and trying to learn how to use them. You look like you're like in the 70s, like Soviet 70s era like space command, which is great. I went on this retreat once that there's this woman talking about where ideas come from and creativity and she asked a big group of people,
并试图学习如何使用它们。你看起来像是在70年代，就像苏联70年代风格的太空指挥中心，这太棒了。我曾经去过一次静修，有一个女人在讲创意从何而来、什么是创造力，她问了一大群人：
where do you come up with your ideas? And a lot of people are like in the shower, in the car, you know, with my kids or whatever, but nobody said in the office. And so you guys, where they work, where they actually are supposed to come up with great ideas. Do you guys get a lot of your, when you're in your studio,
你们的灵感都是从哪来的？很多人说是在淋浴时、在车里，你知道的，和孩子们在一起时之类的地方，但没有人说是在办公室。所以你们，他们工作的地方，他们本该想出伟大创意的地方。你们的很多灵感，当你们在录音室里时，
is that kind of like, does it feel like a dark hole that's like hard to create or does it influence creativity? Different ideas for different things. Like for me, I end up generating a lot of material and Johnny sends me material and then I assemble it all and listen to it in the car.
那种感觉就像是一个难以创作的黑暗洞穴吗，还是说它会激发创造力？不同的东西有不同的想法。对我来说，我最后会产生很多素材，强尼也会发给我素材，然后我把它们全部组合起来，在车里听。
That's a way I find of getting a really good perspective on whatever it is. So things sort of go in stages. You work on something, you say to yourself, I did what this is or Johnny'll send me something, says, what do we do with this? And they just arrive on shuffle for a few weeks and then I can sort of see the next stage.
这是我找到的一个能对任何事物获得很好视角的方法。所以事情是分阶段进行的。你创作了某个东西，你对自己说，这就是它的本来面目，或者强尼会发给我一些东西，说，我们拿这个怎么办？然后它们会在随机播放里呆上几个星期，接着我大概就能看出下一个阶段了。
Okay, maybe this. And then with lyrics, it's something completely different where it'll either be just very quick, very easy or months and months of chipping away, literally line by line and the sort of most painstakingly weird anal kind of trying things, throwing them out,
好吧，也许是这个。然后到了歌词部分，那就是完全不同的情况了，要么非常快、非常轻松，要么就是没完没了地字斟句酌，真的是逐行推敲，那种极其痛苦、古怪、吹毛求疵式的尝试，扔掉，
trying things, throwing them out, trying things, throwing them out. And to the point where sometimes it's just, well, I've got this syllable and I've got this consonant and I've got this syllable and now I'm just going to wait for the rest to turn up. Do you ever have anybody else, Tom,
尝试，扔掉，尝试，扔掉。以至于有时就是，好吧，我有了这个音节，我有了这个辅音，我有了这个音节，现在我只要等剩下的部分自己冒出来就行了。汤姆，你有没有过其他人，
is there somebody in your life, like your wife or your kid, do you ever play music in the car with your kids and look and see how they react? Does that ever happen? Do they think you're as cool as the rest of the world? No. Yeah, yeah.
你生命中有这样的人吗，比如你的妻子或孩子，你有没有和孩子们在车里放音乐，然后观察他们的反应？有过这种事吗？他们觉得你和世界上其他人一样酷吗？没有。对，对。
They do? Oh, good. What about you, Johnny? Do you get feedback off yours? I mean, I know you do. Well, I remember being really anxious that one of my sons wasn't really listening to much music and didn't seem to like music.
他们觉得？哦，太好了。那你呢，强尼？你从他们那里得到反馈吗？我的意思是，我知道你有。嗯，我记得我当时非常焦虑，因为我的一个儿子不太听什么音乐，而且似乎并不喜欢音乐。
And then this was when it was like sort of 12, 11 or something. And then he suddenly said, I found something I really like and it's this artist called Librak. And I thought Librak, yeah, that's an Eastern, that's a German techno guy. I'm sure I've heard of Librak. And he said, but I listen to it all the time.
然后那是他大概12岁、11岁左右的时候。接着他突然说，我找到了一个我真的很喜欢的艺术家，叫利布拉克（Librak）。我想象着利布拉克，是的，那是一个东欧的，那是个德国的电子音乐人。我确信我听说过利布拉克。然后他说，但我一直在听这个。
And I thought, finally, he's got some, you know, exciting cool taste. And he gave me his phone and it was Liberace. I think I dropped my phone. That might have been me. I was kind of, I was totally thrown. I had the same thing. My son, who's now 13,
我想，太好了，他终于有了一些，你知道的，令人兴奋的酷味品味。然后他把手机递给我，那是利伯拉切（Liberace）。我想我手机都掉了。那可能是我。我当时有点，我整个人都懵了。我也有过同样的经历。我儿子现在13岁了，
but when he was about 11 and I didn't know what it, and then I went into his room and we'd given him an old record player and he had the double record of stop making sense, talking heads, the live record. And he was playing it on his own volition that he'd found for a minute. I was like, oh, great.
但当他大约11岁时，我不知道那是什么，然后我走进他的房间，我们送过他一台旧唱片机，他正放着双碟装的《Stop Making Sense》，传声头像（Talking Heads）的现场专辑。他是在自己完全自愿的情况下播放的，他不知道从哪找到的。有那么一分钟，我心想，哦，太好了。
And I'll just leave him be. You don't have to let him enjoy it. And that's a kind of an exciting moment. But do you, do you have those people in your life who are not like Tom, who's not Johnny and Johnny who's not Tom that you listen to the music on your own and they go like, yeah, that's great.
我就让他自己呆着吧。你不用非得让他去享受它。那真是一个让人兴奋的时刻。但是，你们生命中有没有这样的人——不是像汤姆那样不是强尼，也不是强尼那样不是汤姆——当你们独自听音乐时，他们会说，噢，这太棒了。
My son is a musician as well. And he's studying music. And when he comes home, he comes and sits in the studio and starts giving me advice, which I love. It's 21, which is brilliant. And I mean, we literally talk, we just talk about music.
我儿子也是个音乐人。他正在学音乐。当他回家时，他会来录音室坐坐，开始给我提建议，我太喜欢这样了。他21岁了，这太棒了。我的意思是，我们真的就是聊天，我们只聊音乐。
He comes home, we talk about music and instruments. Then he says, right, I'm back to college and that's it. So that's very odd for me. Oh, great. And my daughter comes in and just, well, it's a smile or a scowl, you know, is what I'll get. I've got one of those. And my wife as well.
他回家，我们聊音乐和乐器。然后他说，好啦，我回学校了，就这样。所以这对我来说非常奇怪。哦，太棒了。我女儿进来时，要么是一个微笑，要么就是一个怒容，你知道的，这就是我能得到的。我也有一个这样的。还有我妻子也是。
My wife is like, she'll fix it on a particular song, which is great, you know, and she'll see stuff in it because she's Italian as well. She's not coming to it from a lyrical point of view, necessarily, straight away. You guys should know that last week, and I had no idea that you were going to be on the show, but last four days ago in the car
我妻子会这样，她会迷上一首特定的歌，这太棒了，你知道的，她能从其中看出一些门道，因为她也是意大利人。她不一定会立刻从歌词的角度去理解它。你们应该知道，上周，我完全不知道你们要来上节目，就在四天前，我在车里
with my 19-month-old son playing OK Computer and just watching his... I tilted the rear view so I could watch him in, because he's in the baby seat, so I could see him and see his reaction to it. It was fucking great, man. Great. He was tapping along.
和我19个月大的儿子一起放《OK Computer》，看着他的……我把后视镜调了一下，这样我就可以在后视镜里看他，因为他坐在婴儿座椅里，所以我可以看到他，看他对这首歌的反应。太酷了，伙计。太棒了。他跟着节奏敲打呢。
Yeah. My son Noah was obsessed with autobahn when we were kids, really. Autobahn all the time. Meep, meep. He'd say, meep, meep. When he was like one and a half or whatever. Meep, meep.
对。我儿子诺亚（Noah）在我们小时候对《Autobahn》着迷得不行。一直在听《Autobahn》。哔哔，哔哔。他会说，哔哔，哔哔。当他大概一岁半还是什么时候的时候。哔哔，哔哔。
OK. We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. You've had so many great songs, but aren't you kind of amazed at how many times Creep has been reimagined and reinterpreted? And remember hearing this choir one a long, long time ago?
好的。我们马上回来。好的。欢迎回到节目。你们有过那么多伟大的歌曲，但你们难道不觉得《Creep》被重新构想和重新演绎了那么多次，是一件很神奇的事吗？还记得很久很久以前听到过这个合唱团的版本吗？
Yeah, that was a trailer for a social network. That was amazing. Oh, is that what it is? Yeah. But I've also heard so many other ones. I mean, there's got to be thousands of them. There was one that my friend of mine, Jordan Takahashi, is a fashion designer.
对，那是《社交网络》的预告片。那太惊艳了。哦，是这样的吗？对。但我也听过很多其他版本。我的意思是，肯定有成千上万个版本。有一个版本是我朋友乔丹·高桥（Jordan Takahashi），他是一个时装设计师。
He said, do you have any old versions of Creep that are a bit longer? And I'm like, mate, of course not. So I sent him one that was just basically, he wanted it to be 10 minutes long, so I stretched. I just stretched it for 10 minutes. And it sounded wicked. So that's my favorite version.
他说，你们有没有什么稍微长一点的《Creep》旧版本？我说，老兄，怎么可能有。所以我给他发了一个基本上是——他想要10分钟长的版本，所以我把它拉长了。我硬把它拉长到了10分钟。听起来邪门透顶。所以这是我最喜欢的版本。
What did he want it for? Just for his Walkman. For his Walk thing, you know? Yeah. All these people dressed with space gear on. And it was wicked. So getting back to your kids, do they ask you to take it sometimes to concerts?
他要这个干嘛？只是为了他的随身听。为了他的随身听设备，你知道的？对。所有这些人穿着太空装备。太邪门了。那么回到你们的孩子身上，他们有时会要求你们带他们去演唱会吗？
And if so, what was the last one? Because I've got a 15-year-old daughter and a 10-year-old daughter. And I'm not really thrilled with the kind of music we listen to. Are their musical tastes in line with yours, for the most part? Well, my son doesn't like anything with guitars or drums or anything like that.
如果是的话，最近的一次是哪场？因为我有一个15岁的女儿和一个10岁的女儿。我对我们听的那种音乐并不是真的很兴奋。他们的音乐品味在大多数情况下和你们的一致吗？嗯，我儿子不喜欢任何有吉他、鼓或类似东西的音乐。
So he'll just listen to kind of classical stuff. I have no idea why. Is it though? Yeah. Well, you're talking to a guy who listens to classical music. Thank you, Johnny. Is it though? I mean...
所以他只听古典音乐之类的东西。我不知道为什么。真的是这样吗？对。好吧，你是在和一个听古典音乐的人说话。谢谢你，强尼。真的是这样吗？我的意思是……
I literally listen to Beethoven, Mozart, and Radiohead. That's it. Surely you have to have a kind of angry, never mind the Bollocks phase of music. I studied classical music for 20 years. I am a pianist. And I always thought it was funny when people put on classical music in the background as a soothing kind of thing.
我 literally（简直）只听贝多芬、莫扎特和电台司令（Radiohead）。就这样。你们肯定经历过那种充满愤怒、不管不顾的朋克摇滚阶段吧？我学了20年古典音乐。我是一个钢琴家。我一直觉得很好笑，当人们把古典音乐当成舒缓身心的背景音乐来放的时候。
But it will be like, and they won't know that that back then was like, no, that was hard rock back then. It's not supposed to be in the background while you're cleaning your house. But I thought that was really funny. All right. Well, listen, you guys.
但实际情况是，他们可能并不知道，当年的那些音乐就相当于当年的硬摇滚。它本不该在你打扫房间时当背景音乐放的。但我当时觉得这真的很好笑。好吧。那么，听着，伙计们。
I am just so thankful that you guys said yes to do this. Being respectful of your time. Thank you for giving us some weird... It's been totally fun. I do worry that it's been overly earnest as things often are with us, you know. No, no. Yeah, you know.
我太感激你们答应来做这个了。考虑到你们的时间。谢谢你们给我们带来一些古怪的……这真的太有趣了。我确实担心它会像我们平时那样，变得过于一本正经。不，不。对，你知道的。
Oh, wait, wait. Well, Johnny, say something controversial. That would be, I mean, really helpful. Yeah, let's be idiots for a second. What's your guilty pleasure right now? What are the non-earnest things that you guys are doing? Are you watching some bad reality television? Have you seen The Killing?
哦，等等，等等。好吧，强尼，说点有争议的话吧。那会，我的意思是，真的很有帮助。好吧，让我们当一分钟白痴吧。你们现在有什么罪恶的快感吗？你们在做哪些不正经的事？你们在看什么烂肥皂剧吗？你们看过《谋杀》（The Killing）吗？
Have you seen The Killing? Have you seen Boba Fett? What would you be most embarrassed to tell us about right now? I'm very good at Wordle. Oh, that's the new thing. What's that? Wordle? Is that an app?
你们看过《谋杀》吗？你们看过《波巴·费特之书》（Boba Fett）吗？现在有什么事是你们最不好意思告诉我们的？我很擅长玩Wordle。哦，那是新出的东西。那是什么？Wordle？那是一个应用吗？
Is that a game? Yeah, word games. I love word games. I love word games and crosswords. He does. That's an app I can get? No, it's a website. One person per day.
那是一个游戏吗？对，猜词游戏。我喜欢猜词游戏。我喜欢猜词游戏和填字游戏。他是这样的。那是一个我可以下载的App吗？不，那是一个网站。每人每天一个。
I'm not monetizing it at all. It's amazing. I do that too. Wordle. Yeah, it's great. Is that an app I can get? Hey, why don't you just say I'm old? That's a lot quicker.
我根本没有靠它赚钱。这太神奇了。我也玩那个。Wordle。对，太棒了。那是我能下载的App吗？嘿，你为什么不直接说我老了？那样快得多。
I truly am. Tom, what are you killing your brain with lately? What am I killing my brain with? You mean in terms of entertainment? Yeah. We are currently consuming some... Do you know a TV series called The Leftovers? The Leftovers.
我确实挺老。汤姆，你最近在用什么消磨你的大脑？我用什么消磨我的大脑？你是说在娱乐方面吗？对。我们目前正在看一些……你们知道一部叫《守望尘世》（The Leftovers）的电视剧吗？《守望尘世》。
Oh, God, yes. Oh, God, do we ever... Justin Thoreau. I'm getting sucked into that. That show's fantastic. And how great is that music from Max Richter? Is it Max Richter? Yeah.
哦，天哪，是的。哦，天哪，我们当然知道……贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Thoreau）。我陷进去了。那部剧太棒了。马克斯·里希特（Max Richter）的音乐有多棒？是马克斯·里希特吗？对。
Max Richter? Jason, I didn't know you know him. He's great, isn't he? He's genius. I love him. It's a beautiful show. Tom, if you're watching that right now, Justin is a friend of the show, sadly. And so you can just say hi to him right now.
马克斯·里希特？杰森，我不知道你认识他。他很棒，不是吗？他是天才。我太喜欢他了。这是一部很美的剧。汤姆，如果你现在正在看那个，贾斯汀是本节目的朋友，遗憾的是。所以你现在就可以跟他打个招呼。
He's listening because he's always hoping for a mention. Is he? He's got to mention. It's pretty wicked, got to say. But that was a nice offset to what I watched before, which was down to Naby. So don't tell anyone that. I watched all of them. I loved it.
他在听，因为他总是希望能被提到。是吗？他被提到了。不得不说，这挺邪门的。但这跟我之前看的那部剧形成了很好的反差，我之前看的是《唐顿庄园》（Downton Abbey）。所以别告诉任何人这个。我都看完了。我太喜欢了。
I don't think I want to know the answer to this question, but I have to ask it. Do you have any idea that I've used two Radiohead songs in Ozark? Yes. I was like, that was such a shock. I had no idea it was coming. But... You guys don't approve that stuff, right? I saw the emails.
我觉得我可能不想知道这个问题的答案，但我不得不问。你们知不知道我在《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）里用了两首电台司令的歌？知道。我当时想，这太震撼了。我完全不知道它要播。但是……你们不会批准那种东西的，对吧？我看到了电子邮件。
Wait, did you? Okay, yeah, you guys don't approve that. Skin read it. It was the greatest day of my life when you guys said yes the first time. And then when I heard yes the second time. No, listen, I had no idea that was coming on. And I was watching that episode. And suddenly it's like, I know this.
等等，真的吗？好吧，对，你们不批准那个。扫一眼就行。当你们第一次说“好”的时候，是我生命中最棒的一天。然后当我听到第二次说“好”的时候。不，听着，我完全不知道它会在那儿播。我当时正在看那一集。突然间就觉得，这歌我熟。
And Dexter comes on. No, what it made me think, what it made me think is it made me really like that song and think, oh, that is, you know what? It is good. We struggled with that song a lot. Yeah. So it was nice. You didn't like Dexter.
然后杰克斯（Dexter）出场了。不，它让我想到的是，它让我真正喜欢上那首歌，并觉得，哦，你知道吗？这歌确实好。我们以前为那首歌纠结了很久。对。所以这感觉挺好。你不喜欢杰克斯。
Jason, you used the song that they hate the most. No. We just wanted to do it again. What we worry about is if we recorded it well enough. And it was hearing it in the context of that drama and thinking, oh, this sounds amazing. It does sound amazing. Oh my God.
杰森，你用了他们最讨厌的那首歌。不。我们只是想再试一次。我们担心的是我们把它录得够不够好。在那种戏剧的语境中听到它，就会觉得，哦，听起来太棒了。听起来确实惊艳。哦，天哪。
What a great thing to hear. Is that kind of... Yeah, it just takes your focus off the recording. You're not looking at speakers. You're actually looking at something else. Sometimes it's nice when a record is... It finds a place like that rather than the middle of an album where it's got to compete with other things.
听到这个感觉太棒了。那种……对，它转移了你对录音本身的关注。你不是在盯着音箱看。你实际上是在看别的东西。有时候，当一张专辑被……它能找到这样一个归宿，而不是夹在一张专辑中间去跟别的东西竞争，感觉挺好的。
When it gets isolated and thrown on and tell you in the middle of a scene, a middle of something that's happening that you remember visually, it's great. Man, it stands on its own just fine. What about... You haven't heard Daily Mail in the second season, have you? We put it in a great spot in that too. It's just... Your music is...
当它被剥离出来，扔在某个场景中间，在某个视觉上让你记忆深刻的事情中间播放时，这种感觉太棒了。伙计，它完全能够独立撑起一片天。那……你们第二季里没听过《Daily Mail》吧？我们在那里也把它放在了一个很棒的位置。这简直……你们的音乐是……
Plus is anything. Jason has been a huge fan of... We all have, but Jason is a very vocal fan of yours. And he's been pushing your stuff like a street dealer for... As long as I've known him, which is 20 years, and this is a huge thrill. I can say this for him. It's a huge thrill that you guys said yes to this. And it's a thrill for all of us.
再加上……杰森一直是个超级粉丝……我们都是，但杰森是你们的一个非常公开的粉丝。他像个街头贩子一样狂推你们的东西，从我认识他开始——也就是20年里一直如此，这真的是巨大的震撼。我可以替他这么说。你们能答应来上节目，这对他是巨大的震撼。对我们所有人来说都是震撼。
We're so inspiring and inspired by what you guys do. It's incredible. Thank you so much. But you guys did come off as a little earnest. You were the one who said that. I know. You're selling really earnest. I know, and I just want to buy it back.
你们太鼓舞人心了，而你们的所作所为也激励着我们。这太不可思议了。非常感谢。但你们刚才确实显得有点一本正经。是你自己说的这个。我知道。你们表现得太一本正经了。我知道，我只是想把这话收回。
I want to buy it back. What's your favorite... This is what I'm going to say before. So this is how we're going to buy it back. Do you have a song or do you have a record of yours that you like the most? Just say it if it's true. That's a Sean Hayes question for Christ's sake. Then ask them what their favorite color is afterwards.
我想把它收回。你们最喜欢的……这是我之前要说的。所以我们要这样把它收回。你们有没有一首自己最喜欢的歌或者最喜欢的专辑？如果是真的，就直说吧。这简直是肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）会问的问题，看在上帝的份上。那接下来问问他们最喜欢的颜色是什么。
I'll do that one. I'll do that after this. Brush and blue. Brush and blue. Ask them which one they hate the most. Yeah. Well, Dex Dark is their least favorite song. No, no, no.
我一会儿问那个。我待会儿问。画笔和蓝色。画笔和蓝色。问问他们最讨厌哪一个。对。好吧，杰克·达克（Dex Dark）是他们最不喜欢的歌。不，不，不。
Do least favorite songs become B-sides? Is that what B-sides are? I think it's just that you're sick of the whole album when you release it and you can't bear to look at it or listen to it and think maybe it's all terrible. And that was the moment of like, oh, this sounds great. But then you got to go tour it. Is that why you guys or bands tend to change things a little bit when it's live?
最不喜欢的歌会变成B面单曲吗？B面单曲是这么来的吗？我想这只是因为当你发行一张专辑时，你已经对整张专辑感到厌烦了，你甚至不忍心看它或听它，觉得它可能全都是垃圾。这就是那种“哦，听起来太棒了”的时刻。但随后你必须去进行巡演。这就是为什么你们或乐队在现场演出时往往会做一些小小的改编吗？
Well, you know what it's like. Say you're rehearsing for a theater performance, right? Yeah. You get to do your dress rehearsal. You get to dress rehearsal and all you can see is the holes in everything you're doing and the gaps and the fact that no one's going to get it and blah, blah, blah. And then you go and stand in front of people and it comes to life. It's the same.
嗯，你们知道那是怎样的。假设你正在为一场戏剧演出进行排练，对吧？对。你要进行彩排。你进行彩排时，你所能看到的只有你所做的所有事情中的漏洞、缺口，以及没人能看懂的事实，等等等等。然后你走到人们面前，它就活了过来。这是一样的。
You finish your record. You think, oh, God. Or you feel like you're standing there with your pants down and then you go out and play it in front of people. And then it's a way of getting back to why you did it in the first place. It's great. And I'm sounding really honest again. So, John...
你完成了你的专辑。你心想，哦，天哪。或者你感觉自己就像脱了裤子站在那里，然后你走出去在人们面前演奏它。这是一种找回你最初为什么要这么做的方式。这太棒了。我又听起来一本正经了。所以，约翰……
Wait, Tom, I was going to say the way you said that, Tom. The way you said that, you went holes. You know that the beginning of what is it? Holes. As in holes. As in holes. Yeah. It's Andy Warhol, isn't it?
等等，汤姆，我正想说你刚才说话的方式，汤姆。你刚才说话的方式，你说了“holes”（漏洞）。你知道那是哪首歌的开头吗？《Holes》。就是《Holes》。就像《Holes》一样。对。是安迪·沃霍尔（Andy Warhol）的歌，对吧？
Yeah. Andy Warhol. God, the way you said that just... That was weird. Okay. Sorry. I was obsessed with that record. Same.
对。安迪·沃霍尔。天哪，你刚才说话的那种方式简直……太诡异了。好吧。抱歉。我以前对那张专辑着迷得不行。我也是。
Same, same. Obsessed when I was like 12 years old. That record. Oh, same, same. Hunky Dory is. Especially the photograph on the back, you know, with all this handwritten thing, like the way it's scrolled on. Yes, yes, yes.
一样，一样。我大概12岁的时候就着迷得不行。那张专辑。哦，一样，一样。《Hory Dory》就是。尤其是封底的那张照片，你知道的，上面有所有这些手写的字，就像草书一样。对，对，对。
The photo of him standing there with his enormous pants on and the long hair is like, oh, man, that's the coolest thing I've ever seen. And who did that great strumming? Who played that guitar on that record? It was so... Well, I think he did the acoustic, didn't he? And the others was... But he had...
那张他站在那里、穿着巨大裤子、留着长发的照片简直是——哦，伙计，这是我见过最酷的东西。是谁弹了那么棒的吉他扫弦？那张专辑里的吉他是谁弹的？简直是……嗯，我想他弹了木吉他，对吧？其他的则是……但他找了……
No, he had somebody else on that. It's so luscious. There's something about the way he plays that acoustic guitar, if it's him, on that record. God. Which album is this? Hunky Dory. Hunky Dory. No, I am.
不，那上面还有别人。太美妙了。如果那是他的话，他在那张专辑里弹奏木吉他的方式有一种特别的魅力。天哪。这是哪张专辑？《Hunky Dory》。《Hunky Dory》。不，我是说。
So incredible. You ready? Yeah. Sorry. No, keep going. No, I know. Yeah, please. I know.
太不可思议了。准备好了吗？对。抱歉。不，继续。不，我知道。对，请继续。我知道。
I'm boring these guys. Yeah, we're going. Not at all. Give me some more. Thank you, gentlemen. Thank you. You guys are the best. You were not earnest at all.
我在烦扰这几位。对，我们走吧。一点也没有。再给我讲点。谢谢你们，绅士们。谢谢。你们是最棒的。你们一点也不一本正经。
You were an absolute dream. You were very polite to indulge us with our, or my earnest questions. I had some legitimate fan questions about the band. So thank you for that and your process and all that. It's lovely. It's been nice talking to you guys. We'll get stupid next time. We'll do a part two, yeah, the other way around.
你们绝对是梦幻般的嘉宾。你们非常客气地包容了我们的，或者说我那些一本正经的问题。我确实有一些关于乐队的合理歌迷问题。所以谢谢你们解答这些以及谈论你们的创作过程之类的内容。这太美妙了。和你们聊天很开心。下次我们要变蠢一点。我们做个第二部分，对吧，反过来弄。
Okay. Thank you, guys. Enjoy the rest of your day. Thanks, you guys. Nice to meet you. Thank you, Jason. Lovely to meet you. Nice to meet you.
好的。谢谢你们，伙计们。享受剩下的时光吧。谢谢你们，伙计们。很高兴认识你们。谢谢你，杰森。很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你们。
Bye, guys. Bye, guys. Good job. Good job. You can just slam your laptops now. Did that really happen? I don't think it did. Hope.
再见，伙计们。再见，伙计们。干得好。干得好。你们现在可以把笔记本电脑摔了。刚才真的发生了吗？我觉得没有。希望如此。
What? Did it? How was I? You were terrible. Can I just say this? I know. I want to be honest and I'm going to speak for the audience. It was cute because you were super into it, but you were such a bully about asking questions.
什么？发生了吗？我表现得怎么样？你太糟糕了。我能说这个吗？我知道。我想实话实说，我要代表观众发言。这挺可爱的，因为你太投入了，但你追问起问题来简直像个恶霸。
Well, you wouldn't fucking let. I got, I got 25. These are my heroes. You never took your foot off the gas. You never took your, Sean, am I right? No, I thought, I thought everybody did a wonderful job. Sean, you know what? No, Jason, I'm giving you a hard time.
好吧，你根本不会放过……我有25个。这些可是我的偶像。你从来没有把脚从油门上移开。你从来没移开过，肖恩，我说的对吗？不，我觉得，我觉得每个人都做得很好。肖恩，你知道吗？不，杰森，我是在逗你玩。
You were great. I know you love them so much and that's why I had to tell them because I knew that you couldn't even really say it in the way you wanted to. Well, it's hard when it's your guests and you really, really like them. I know. I know it's hard. They're great. I was, I did, I did some prep for this.
你表现得很棒。我知道你太爱他们了，这就是为什么我不得不说出来，因为我知道你甚至无法以你想要的方式说出来。好吧，当他们是你的嘉宾，而你又真的、真的很喜欢他们的时候，这就很难了。我知道。我知道这很难。他们太棒了。我做了，我为这次采访做了一些准备。
I was up, I was up two hours ago writing questions. It's only got to half of them. Wow. Well, we'll have them back on. Yeah. But my God, I still can't really understand what they're doing here. I know. Do you think they saw you on promises, promises, Sean?
我两个小时前就起来写问题了。结果只问了一半。哇。好吧，我们会请他们再来的。对。但天哪，我还是无法真正理解他们为什么会来这里。我知道。肖恩，你觉得他们看过你演的《许诺，许诺》（Promises, Promises）吗？
Do you think that's what it was? They must have heard of Reese's commercial. It must be. How about, how about my question about the doc and I'm like, would you guys ever do it? They didn't want it. I was so embarrassed. I know. No, they did.
你觉得是那个原因吗？他们肯定听说过里茨（Reese's）的广告。肯定是。还有，我问关于纪录片的那种问题，我说，你们会考虑拍一部吗？他们根本不想拍。我当时尴尬极了。我知道。不，他们拍过。
I was wondering about correcting you on that, but then I thought, well, it would be rude if I didn't know that. Right. Right. You're allowed to not know it. Yeah. Because they're not your guests. For sure.
我当时在想要不要纠正你，但我转念一想，我要是连这都不知道，那就太粗鲁了。对吧。对吧。你可以不知道。对啊。因为他们又不是你的嘉宾。肯定的。
You know who's a huge Radiohead fan is Bradley Cooper. Brad, I remember when kid A, he was like, he couldn't stop talking about it. Dude, dude, dude, dude. Radiohead dude. Radiohead. You know how he gets like super. I don't know how they keep making every song, every album totally different than the last one.
你知道谁是个超级电台司令迷吗？布莱德利·库珀（Bradley Cooper）。布拉德，我记得《Kid A》刚出来的时候，他简直赞不绝口。兄弟，兄弟，兄弟，兄弟。电台司令迷。电台司令。你知道他那种超级狂热的样子。我不知道他们是怎么做到让每一首歌、每一张专辑都和上一张完全不同的。
No, it's incredible. Super challenging and it ends up being even better than the last album. You know what's wild too is like, I think the, like personalities that we've had musicians on the show before, they all seem very kind of docile and interviews and very kind of quiet. And then you get on stage and they're like running around, you know, crazy singing, jumping screaming their heads off like they, they're just so effusive and come out of their bodies when they're performing.
不，这太不可思议了。超级具有挑战性，而且结果往往比上一张专辑还要好。疯狂的是，我觉得，以前上过我们节目的音乐人，他们在采访中看起来都非常温顺，而且非常安静。然后你到了现场，他们就像疯了一样到处跑，疯狂地唱歌、跳跃、声嘶力竭地尖叫，就像他们……在表演时完全解放了天性，灵魂出窍了一样。
But that's their space. Like they're not, musicians aren't, they're not, they didn't sign up for like doing interviews and on camera stuff and all that. You know, it's like, like athletes, you know, they're running around like crazy on the field, but you put a camera in front of them and you know, that's not their natural spot. And so I think they're appropriately reserved. Yeah. I just think it's interesting.
但那是他们的空间。音乐人不是那种……他们没有报名参加采访、面对镜头之类的活动。你知道的，就像运动员一样，他们在球场上疯狂奔跑，但你把摄像机怼到他们面前，你知道的，那不是他们自然的舒适区。所以我认为他们保持适当的保留是合理的。对。我只是觉得这很有趣。
I've always loved this lyric of theirs, which is, I mean, just to, which is, I'm reading it obviously, but it's her green plastic watering can for her fake Chinese rubber plant in the fake plastic earth that she bought from a rubber man in a town full of rubber plants to get rid of itself. And I just want to say, how does he come up with that? And I want to say, man, take a knee. Okay. Cause you've written something crazy.
我一直很喜欢他们歌里的一句歌词，我是说，仅仅为了……这句词是——我当然是在照本宣科——“她为自己买自橡胶人的充满虚假中国橡胶植物的绿色塑料浇花壶，在一个满是橡胶植物的小镇里，为了摆脱自身”。我只想说，他是怎么想出这种词的？我想说，老兄，请受我一拜。好吧。因为你写出了如此疯狂的东西。
And you've written something really at the same time, simultaneously, really, I think it's profound. Well, that was one of the things I wanted to ask him when he was talking about lyrics. Mind blowing. But I didn't want to embarrass him and prompt him into giving an earnest answer. But how do you grind and make such great lyrics, such sort of, you know, off center and then not articulate them in the song or on stage such that people can hear them verbatim and appreciate their specificity.
你写出了如此深刻的东西，而且同时兼具了这两点，真的，我认为这非常深刻。好吧，这正是我在谈到歌词时想问他的事情之一。太震撼了。但我不想让他尴尬，也不想催促他给出一个一本正经的回答。但是，你该如何千锤百炼写出如此棒的歌词，如此出其不意，然后又不在歌曲中或舞台上把它们清晰地表达出来，好让人们能够逐字听清并欣赏其独特性呢？
You know, like people who write poetry, they really love that they're writing poetry and you can read it and know exactly what they said. Oftentimes lyrics, you can't understand what the singer is saying. Yeah, because poetry, that in that medium, that that's what is sort of incumbent upon the writer to that's how you express it through those words. The words need to be heard in that way with a song. It's not necessarily about the words at all. As we know, lots of songs have no words.
你知道的，就像写诗的人一样，他们非常热爱写诗，你可以阅读它，并且确切知道他们在说什么。通常歌词里，你是听不清歌手在唱什么什么的。是的，因为诗歌，在这种媒介中，那是作家所肩负的责任，这就是你通过这些文字表达的方式。这些文字需要以那种方式在歌曲中被听到。它根本不一定关乎文字本身。正如我们所知，很多歌根本没有歌词。
Right. So he's clearly taking care to really craft each word. Right, but then you just, you buy the album and you read the lyrics. Yeah, that's part of the discovery. We're like, I always think to, you know, it's kind of like we were saying when we had David Burn on about like, what is that, what did that mean to you? You know, because those lyrics meant so much to so many people. He's like, oh, I was just trying to imitate the member of the AM radio.
对吧。所以他显然很用心去精心雕琢每一个字。对，但然后你买下专辑，你去读歌词。对，那是探索的一部分。我们就像，我总是觉得，你知道的，这有点像我们之前采访大卫·伯恩（David Byrne）时谈到的，“那是什么意思？那对你意味着什么？”你知道的，因为那些歌词对太多人意义重大。他说，“哦，我只是在模仿AM广播里的某个成员。”
They meant nothing to me. So I'm sure I don't know, but you could, I would imagine, I wish we had asked them if, you know, if all of us could have had a question on there other than Jason. He said to him, he probably would have said, yeah, the words mean something to me, but if you interpreted it a different way, that's great too. I love that part of, we don't need to boil it all down to what does this mean? What is this black and white? It's just kind of open to interpretation.
它们对我来说毫无意义。所以我敢说我肯定不知道，但你可以，我想象如果能问他们就好了，要是我们所有人都能除了杰森之外也提个问题的话。他跟他说过，他大概会回答说：“这些词对我有意义，但如果你解读出不同的意思，那也很好。”我很喜欢这种做法，我们不需要把一切都简化为：这到底是什么意思？这黑白分明的是什么？它就是开放式的，任人解读。
I felt badly bringing up the song creep, but it's like, yeah, it's a gigantic, massive, historical song now. Yeah, he did feel badly. I remember he was saying his friend asked for it and he sent him this. But just like any band would like their big hit back then. You're going to be called, you're going to be asked about Ozark the rest of your life. I mean, you asked about Will and Grace. You're going to be asked about rest development, both of you.
我提到《Creep》这首歌时觉得挺不好意思的，但它现在确实是一首庞大、巨大、具有历史意义的歌曲了。对啊，他确实觉得挺不好意思的。我记得他说过是他的朋友点名要听，然后他才发给他的。不过就像任何乐队在当时都希望自己的大热单曲回来一样。你以后整个人生都会被问到《黑钱胜地》相关的问题。我是说，你会被问到《威尔与格蕾丝》，你们俩都会被问到《发展受阻》。
You know, I mean, everybody gets asked about that one big thing. Right. They just probably hate playing it live. I bet. I bet. Yeah, I wonder if they do though. Again, it would have been nice to have had the opportunity to interview Radiohead. Guys, I've been nervous about this for six weeks.
你知道我的意思，每个人都会被问到那件最红的大事。没错。他们可能只是讨厌现场表演吧。我敢打赌。我敢打赌。对啊，我也想知道他们是不是真的讨厌。话说回来，如果有机会采访到电台司令乐队，那可真是太好了。伙计们，为此我紧张了足足六个星期。
Wow. Okay. It's been hard for me not to mention it's either one of you. Yeah. Oh God, I'm so glad it's over. They're one of the greats. They'll go down in history as one of the greatest bands. They were cool guys.
哇。好吧。对我来说，一直忍着不在你们两个面前提起它真的很不容易。是的。哦天哪，我太高兴这一切终于结束了。他们是伟大的乐队之一。他们将被载入史册，成为最伟大的乐队之一。他们人很酷。
And obviously, you know, they're, I know you hate when I use the term artists, but God, these guys are real artists. And listen, it's sort of asymmetric and atypical. Atypical. You fucking, you buried that word. Today. Atypical too. They're going to be, they're clowning you right now in a text chain.
很显然，你知道的，他们是——我知道你讨厌我用“艺术家”这个词，但天哪，这几位真的是真正的艺术家。而且听着，这有点非对称、非典型。非典型。你他妈的，你把这个词给埋汰了。今天。非典型也是。他们现在正私下发群消息拿你开涮呢。
I was nervous. I'm sure they are. They are clowning you. They're like, mate, did you hear this fucking joke? They think we're the biggest idiotic American wankers of all time, guaranteed right now. They're like, who the fuck made us go and get interviewed by these American wankers? I know. By the way, have you seen the new American wankers?
我刚才很紧张。我敢肯定他们是。他们真的在拿你开涮。他们大概会说：“伙计，你听到这个傻逼笑话了吗？”他们百分之百在想，我们简直是有史以来最白痴的美国傻帽，此刻他们绝对这么觉得。他们会想：“到底是谁他妈让我们来接受这群美国傻帽采访的？”我知道。顺便问一句，你看过那部新的《美国傻帽》吗？
It's so good. It's on AMC. Oh, it's so good. They have the big come to Jesus moment. It's about an orgy in a church. Wait, what? Yeah. American wankers.
太好看了。在AMC播出。哦，太赞了。他们有个重大的顿悟时刻。讲的是教堂里的群交派对。等等，什么？对。美国傻帽。
But I'm starting to think about a bye. Do you guys have a good one? I have the word alibi, but I don't know how to do that. Oh, well, that's the thing in the killing. I watched that show. The guy, the Danish one. The Danish show. And I'm at the part right now where the guy, they thought he did it, but it turned out he
不过我开始在考虑不在场证明了。你们有谁能想出个好主意吗？我有“不在场证明”这个词，但我不知道该怎么用。哦，对了，那就是《谋杀》里的那个桥段。我看过那部剧。那个家伙，那个丹麦人演的。那部丹麦剧。我现在看到的那部分是，那个家伙，大家以为是他干的，但结果证明他
had a really good alibi. Oh, bye, guys. And now, listener, you're welcome. What we've done is we've created an ear baby. We have mated, smart, less and radio head. And our little bouncing baby boy song is about to enter your ears. This is the courtesy of our doula, Rob Armyarve. This show is a smart list.
有个非常完美的不在场证明。哦，再见，各位。现在，听众朋友们，不用谢。我们做了一件什么事呢？我们创造了一个“耳朵宝宝”。我们把“聪明绝顶”和“电台司令”结合在了一起。我们这个活泼可爱的小男婴歌曲马上就要钻进你们的耳朵里了。这是由我们的接生员罗布·阿尔米亚夫倾情呈现。这个节目是“聪明绝顶”。
Welcome to the smart list. Welcome to the smart list. Welcome to the smart list. And welcome to smart list. Smart list is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armyarve, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Henry, smart, less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欢迎收听“聪明绝顶”。欢迎收听“聪明绝顶”。欢迎收听“聪明绝顶”。欢迎来到“聪明绝顶”。“聪明绝顶”是100%纯天然、由罗布·阿尔米亚夫、本内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·亨利手工匠造的。“聪明绝顶”。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。